what do you do so I work as an airline
pilot yeah oh my God Bruno that's like a
an attractive job yes well yeah I just
want to be you yeah Bruno you don't you
have no idea who you are you're a very
good looking guy from Madrid who's an
airline pilot I mean you've got it made
I don't know I don't know what do you
mean I don't know you're lying to me
yeah he's got a guitar in the background
yeah you just can't get cooler yeah come
on when you're wearing the uniform I
just bet it's magic I I have to say do
you have the Hat could you put it on
indulge us oh my God what oh no no no
way no no no so
um women only come and ask me about
where where is the baggage claim built
and oh but listen let me tell you
something Bruno that's the oldest come
on in the book
me do you know where the luggage thing
is and I know right away that's code for
I am DTF
and guess what then suddenly everybody's
upset
because I misread the situation and they
just wanted to find the luggage
compartment
um so what's it like you are I'm sorry
I'm trying to wrap my mind around this
Bruno you travel the world you're a very
good looking and humble airline pilot
from Madrid you've got the accent the
look you're wearing the you does your
uniform have little epaulettes on the
shoulders yeah damn it I want to wear
epaulettes I would I have to say if I
was flying and you were in the cockpit I
would I would just keep making excuses
to come up and talk to you I would yeah
I know and not in in that way you know
I'm in a hijacking way
[Laughter]
do you like being an airline pilot yeah
I love it it's a very nice gig
um it's not for everyone though it's uh
it's got its ups and downs okay
is I mean I know the upsides would be
you're traveling you've got the uniform
with the epaulettes uh there's lots of
upsides as far as I can see what are the
downsides well it's not very easy to mix
it with your personal life you know you
could work a lot of weekends and bank
holidays you're away from home
so yeah it's a bit hard to organize your
life really so you really need to to to
love it yeah yeah probably hard to
establish a steady stable relationship
you're probably forced to have many uh
different relationships
yeah
and it's so hard not to mix the names
you know
hey Bruno Bruno tell me about it okay
because you know I wasn't an airline
pilot but you know talk show host
podcaster different town every night
um
the two of you could not be more
different you are my exact opposite
Bruno in every way
um yeah I can see that do you think I
would make a good pilot Bruno do you
think I have what it takes
uh you know oh come on maybe and he's
honest well tell me be honest Bruno give
your assessment I think maybe you're the
length of your legs would be an issue
with the rubber pedals oh so that's
something to have in mind
um but maybe if they make a special
cockpit for you you know maybe it's a
special cockpit what am I the Elephant
Man I want to be honest with you because
I don't know how this works but I tend
to panic a lot I was wondering I get
very panicky
um and I might be someone who would
constantly be putting the plane into a
power dive or a power climb is that
going to be an issue yeah you could be
an aerobatic pilot maybe like a very
panicky or aerobatic pilot okay all
right maybe that's my field I don't I
also don't think you're
if you're in that kind of tense
situation like if there's a lot of
turbulence yeah I'd probably say hey uh
attention ladies and gentlemen uh this
is the most turbulence I've encountered
I don't know what the going on
open my window and get off this plane
those are the kind of announcements that
I would be giving
would you be comfortable having me in
the cockpit with you no no and I think
you would probably enter the Flight Deck
with a parachute too so yes
on my chest and my back and I'd be
holding a vomit bucket uh
and I'd have my Airlines Pilot's hat on
backwards and sideways so it would be a
bad look all around